Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and I'm going to beat this game!
I've literally got all day long. I don't care how long it takes!
I've got all damn day, I'm gonna play this until I beat it because I'm tired of people constantly going,
"Why don't you play Vanish again? What, are you a big scaredy baby cat?"
and I'm like, have you seen the shit that this game puts me through?
Have you seen the bullhonky, I have been playing this game for hours and there's been like, hours of time where I've tried it one more time, I thought,
Hey, I'll throw up the webcam and I'll try to record it and just maybe it'll not be a giant douche to me.
But no! It is, and I scrap like hours of recordings because I'm like, OHHH I can't possibly do this again!
I've got nothing left to talk about this game.
I've done like six episodes and it's the same thing over and over! And yet it still manages to screw me over!
So here I am, one last time, I'm gonna play this game until I beat it and I don't care how long it takes.
But like I said, I don't really have anything else to talk about!
So I'm gonna tell you guys about the history of America, because I got nothing else to talk about.
So, as Americans, if you don't know already, if you do then - I mean, sing along with me as you recite the history - the illustrious history of America.
We wake up each morning and then praise the wooden teeth of George Washington,
and say our daily prayers to the blessed beard of Abraham Lincoln from his top hat to his lovely beard.
May he keep us safe as we go along and thank our creators for our daily McDonald hamburger. Muah, it's delicious.
But anyway, the history...uh, America was founded in like 1480 fuck, I don't know, on the principle of fuck you.
That is America, that is the American way, we have always taught our children great - straight from birth, fuck you!
And just fuck all y'all, and go to hell and let's see how badly we can screw up the entire world.
So anyway! We landed on the shores of New Jersey and the Swole Native Americans came out and they were like,
Sup, nerds? Nice belts on your hats, and we were all -
We're British at this time so we're like,
(British accent) I don't much care for you! Mm, I don't think we're going to get along, oh no, we're starving!
And then they're like - the Native American was like, you need some protein, bruh, here, take this fish and this corn thing.
And we're like, what's corn? And we're like, eating the corn and then we're like,
Oh, this is awesome, you guys are amazing! Hey, can we have all this country?
and the Swole Native Americans were like, I dunno, that doesn't seem very fair to us.
and then they go off their business and we're like, we gotta get rid of these guys 'cause we're suddenly turning into giant assholes.
And then we decide to go try to be friends with them and the Swole Native Americans were like,
Hey, bruh! Goddammit, so many dead ends here. Oh, come on!
Don't - AHH FUCK YOU!
(sighs)
So anyway, the Swole Native Americans (laughs) were going about their business and we were just like,
Hey, you need anything from us, I don't know, disease, starvation, bullets to the head? You need anything at all?
And they were like, oh, you know, we're ok, we're - we're doing just fine living amongst the land peacefully
and not being total asshole Americans like you guys are. We didn't even know what America was but you guys were just giant douches.
And so we decided, oh, we could - we could - we could cooperate!
You - you might need something from us, we might need something from you, and it was like,
Maybe we need more sweat towels for our massive workouts 'cause Native Americans are so amazingly awesome, and they are, but we were like,
Oh, oh yeah, yeah yeah, sure, yeah, sure. Hey, uh, Smallpox Larry! You got a few spare blankets that we could toss -
AND THEN WE KILLED 'EM ALL! And we killed 'em all and that's how we started our tradition of fuck you,
and then we went across our - how many dead ends do I need to frickin' -
(mocking noises) Yeah, you get outta here, you bitch!
And then, then we were total dickbags, Americans founded their entire nation on killing people and taking their stuff,
and then we are where we're here today, throughout George Washington and Abraham Lincoln and the blessed Ben Franklin,
may his glasses watch us from high above, where he is certainly watching us from that great big McDonald's in the sky.
And that's the history of America. That's literally all I've got for this episode.
Unless for some damn reason you want me to tell more history of Am - what is - what is, what am I even doing here.
I don't even - (chokes) - I don't even know what I'm talking about -
Ohh, shut the hell up! Shut the hell up.
Shut up! I don't wanna play your game anymore!
I don't wanna play, I'm only five minutes in. Barely, if that. I don't even think I'm five minutes in.
I'm only five minutes in and I'm already up to my ears in hate for this game.
I've got so much disdain and dislike and other "dis" words and - god, it's - I'm like, have I been missing pages?
Have I been so unbelievably distracted with the amazingly interesting history of America that I can't possibly...
(sighs) I don't even know anymore. I am far too energetic for this crap.
I am far too hopped up on ten thousand gallons of caffeine, I literally, like,
I don't drink coffee a lot, I drank like two giant tall things from Starbucks, I don't even get coffee much from there
but it was like, this espresso thing. It was big, I dunno.
Oh, an arrow, huh? I'll follow that! 'Cause that's probably legitimate.
I don't know. I don't know! If I could just find something I would be more than happy to go about my way.
But as it stands, I've got nothin - oh good! I swear! On this one playthrough, where I stated very clearly I was gonna play until I finally beat it,
I run into all the dead ends! I've never ran into this many dead ends in the entirety of me playing, and I've only been playing for like five minutes!
[hissing]
So how 'bout you go screw yourself while you strange noises in -
(gasps) Ooh. Ok, maybe I'm sorry! I found me some glowy sticks! Ooh, baby, this is gonna be good!
[boom]
I forgot about that. I forgot that that happened. That almost always gets me.
But not this time because I'm too hopped up on freedom and America. I love my country too much to be distracted by these douches over here.
Uhh! So now I just need to find everything else that I need!
Maybe dead ends are good and I'll be able to go about my way, and if I find a dead end then maybe the correct way will be...
[hissing]
...more properly established, ok, this is getting creepier.
I forgo - wha - NO!
Don't - don't fool with me!
Don't fool with me here! Don't fool with me here!
You can't possibly be fooling with me here! You can't possibly!
[hissing]
Oh, by the blessed beard of Ben Franklin, you didn't have a beard but I don't even care anymore!
If you get me to the ding dong damn door I will love you forever! I will forgive you, for everything that you've done to me!
Oh, please! Oh, now I gotta be careful! Now I gotta be careful because if I see someone I'm gonna be so dead!
No! No, I see you! Back away slowly!
Uh, is he following me? Huh, screw it, I'm outta here, I'm outta here!
I can't possibly be anyhabajgah!
I might ubuabhbah - AH! Uhhh!
Oh my goodness globby gracious! I might actually beat this game!
I cannot believe it. I can't believe it. I-I...I - I've never even gotten...I've never gotten the keys this early.
I've never gotten anything this early! Oh my god, is it gonna getmebabhbeatit?
Oh my god, is it let me gonna beat it!
[hissing]
Shut up! No, not this time, please please please please
please please please please please please!
(gasps) NO OHO OH NO, NONONONONONONONONO
Nonononononono!
Nonononono nooo!
You're gonna not be a dick, is he still behind me, I don't know how long he follows.
But I know that there's not a gap here, if they corner me and sandwich me I'm gonna so unbelievably mad!
Please let me beat it. Just this once! Just once!
Oh, by the wooden beeth - teeth of Washington! Ok, which way do I go?
Is it behind me? Ok, bah - huh. Oh...by Thomas Jefferson's...um, proclivity to have sex with his slaves!
Oh, by the way, Americans, we loved our slaves back then apparently.
[clicking]
That was a good part of our history, did I not talk about that? Yeah, that happened a lot.
Ok. I don't like that way.
Ah, these glowsticks! They don't do nothing!
I know I've said that before in previous playthroughs, but absolutely, now I'm definitely getting the feeling!
That they suck giant ass balls! Oh, come on, please!
Please please please! Please gimme a door! A gate! The end!
PLEASE! Please, I am begging you so much I am spitting everything I just ate.
Huhuuhh! Huhuuh, please!
I just want to end the torment!
[hissing]
It's neverending! It's endless AGONY!
NO YOU DON'T! NOT THIS TIME! I'M READY FOR YA!
I'm gonna beatcha! And then you're gonna go about your way, and I'm gonna kill you! Or you're not gonna kill me!
And then I'm gonna get outta here and I'm gonna tell all my friends to bring their guns down here because Americans are given guns at birth!
We give our - we're given guns before we're even able to walk!
We're bottle fed mashed...hamburgers! And french fries and wash it all down milkshakes.
And then we get out little chairs that drive us around! How did I find -
AAHH GAAAHAHAAA!
(cries)
I can't! I can't do it! I can't stop it! I can't stop it!
(choking sounds) I can't do it. I can't do it!
(slurps)
(whines) Where did he come from? Whyyy? Why did I find the steam maintenance room twice?
Ohh...going again.
More American history! Now that I'm not going to - oh god.
More American history. So that was before the British invasion of 1779...
...whereby we declared our independence from the tea-sipping sissies from across the pond.
[hissing]
Oh good! Good for me! I found this! That's good, right?
That's good, it's real gooood. I found glowsticks.
[boom]
Boom, bitch! Alright!
(whines)
Ok. So anyway, the British didn't like us very much because we weren't drinking their tea.
'Cause we Americans like coffee. We dip our hamburger and donuts into coffee every morning and then we drink that,
and then we pray to the American flag, which has a big middle finger on it, by the way,
I don't know if any of you actually looked it up, it's just - just a big middle finger at everyone else in the world at how much better we apparently are than them!
And then we go about our day just waving our flag down the street. Parading every morning, singing to the high heavens how great...uh..
Ulysses S. Grant was, I don't know. I don't frickin' know. I don't know anymore.
I just wanna win! I can't talk about American history! I can't!
UHH! You get outta here! You get outta here! Dat's right, keep on steppin'!
Oh, come one, how long is this tunnel?
There we go! Good. Now, where am I?
Ok, nevermind! Sorry! Sorry sorry sorry. Meant to go this way. Went the other way accidentally.
Now this time don't come up behind me and snap my neck! Because I do not much appreciate that.
Keep on swimming, keep on swimming! Keep on swimming? Keep on swimming.
Keep on swimmiiiing! Swimmiiiing!
Whee, that helps me a LOT!
Hehahaheuu! You get outta here with that noise!
You get outta here! You get outta here with that noise! I'll go this way, then. Don't you be still following me! I don't much appreciate it!
[hissing]
The British people over there who are a delightful bunch decided that they wanted to kick our ass.
So they swam over, like they all just got in the water and started swimming over here,
and then they just individually punched every one of the colonists in the face and we were like,
Ow, that really hurt! Hey, wait a minute! We remembered our holy doctrine of GUNS!
Ah! Don't ever look back, don't follow the pipes, don't RUUUN!
FUCK
FUCK YOU
FUCK YOU PIECE OF
FUCK YOU PIECE OF ASS!
Ok, so it told me not to run, not to follow the pipes, and never to look back. So that's what I'm gonna do!
'Cause whatever! Pipes go that way? Wha, I dunno!
So anyway, the colonists got each punched in the face and we were really peeved off about it,
and we decided we were gonna do something about those naughty British people over there.
So we teamed up with some Canadians or something and they were like,
Oh, eh, what's going' on here, we don't like tea either!
and they're like, oh ok, maybe we should team up and punch them in the face.
So then the colonists and the British were just punching each other in the face over and over and over again,
and they were like, oh I sure wish we didn't kill all those Native Americans, maybe they could help us out.
Oh no, wait, they're still pissed at us because we're assholes, and we never like to make any friends!
So then we go along our way and we're like, ahh, for about five years of -
No, I didn't mean to press run! I was trying to go this whole way without pressing run.
God dingus dammit, my fingers fucuhhh! AHG!
That probably ruined it all for me, I'm never gonna win now because I ran or whatever.
Great! This is because I ran, isn't it?!
This is because I ran, isn't it?!
'Cause I ran. Go screw yourself!
Go and - go, go, go away!
So anyway, more history. We decided to team up with the Canadians and the French and we're like,
Those British guys sure are douches, right? And they're like, I know, right?
And so we eventually started getting our asses kicked but then we started kicking their asses.
And then we go about our way and we start waving our middle finger up in the air and we're like,
Haha, you British people suck! You only control the rest of the world but not us! So...then we go about our business for about 100 years
and then we win two world wars, we think. And then we get to the baby boomers where everyone's having a bunch of sexicals...
...all the time.
No. No! No!
Uh...just...kill me!
Just kill me, you bastard!
(cries)
I turned up the brightness because I couldn't see anything and now I can, so whatever, that's good too.
SHUT UP, STEAM! I've seen you in too many games now, I just don't give an ass!
I don't give an ass about anything! I don't give an ass about America, I don't give an ass about George Washington,
I don't give an ass about Mount Rushmore, and now the FBI is rushing to my house to take me off the internet,
throw me in a room where I can't even praise the American flag every morning! I'll never have hamburgers again!
Shut! Your mouth!
(chipmunk Markiplier)
Uhuuuhhuuhaah! I can't do it, guys. I cannot do it, it is literally impossible for me to win.
I'm never gonna win! Oh look! Right off the BAT! A dead end!
(slurps)
Excuse my spit! Excuse my prolific amounts of spit!
'Cause this game...is a dickbag. And I'm a dickbag for playing it! I'm a dickbag for thinking that I could win.
I'm a dickbag for thinking that I can have any sort of success in this game! 'Cause it sucks ass!
And ass it will suck for the remainder of forever.
(chipmunk Markiplier)
You know, this game is actually long since stopped scaring me? I only play it...I literally only play it because you guys want me to.
Well, shit!
Why won't you let me win?
[hissing]
Why will you not let me have...just a little bit of satisfaction in your fffucking game!
Why won't - why? Why, what have I ever done to you? What have I every done to you, game?
Developers of this game, why is it coded to know that I'm playing it? And never let me win!
Why is it always coded for that?
[hissing]
Why is it always coded?! It's hard coded into the game to know if I'm playing, if Markiplier is playing, he does not deserve to win!
Because you have some -
Because you have some - FUCK YOU!
Fahnahnahnahdah! Dahdahdahdahdahdah!
Dah - bahnahnahnahnah! Bahnahnahnahnahnah!
(sighs)
WHY MUST YOU HATE ME? JUST KILL ME, FUCK YOU!
(groans)
I haven't even been able to find the generator room or the whatever the hell the other room is in a long time!
I just haven't been able to find 'em! 'Cause, you know what...that's my life, this is apparently what I deserve.
This is what I get. This is what I get. This is what I get for thinking that I could actually make good videos for the internet!
This is what I get for playing the gooood games! Gooood horror games!
This is what I get for saying it's a gooood horror game! 'Cause it's BAD! It's very BAAAD! It's very BAAAD!
I'm gonna lose my voice. Because it's bad!
There's so much spit everywhere. There is literally more spit all over my - my desktop monitor than I've ever spit before in my life.
I'm gonna lose all my body fluids, BY SPITTING 'EM!
Why can't I beat you?! WHY? It - it should be literally impossible that I haven't beaten you!
I've played you for hours! HOURS! Random chance should've been on my side by now!
RANDOM CHANCE!
This is far beyond random, I know, this is far beyond random at this point. This is pretty much fate, that I'm never gonna be able to beat you!
You are intentionally dicking with me! I have looked up walk-throughs! It's totally random! There is no strategy!
There is no special key! IT'S JUST RANDOM! AND I HATE YOU!
I HATE YOU!
Every one...every one of these corridors...every one of 'em! Has a monster!
[hissing]
Good! Good for you!
Shut
Shut the
Shut the eff
Shut the eff up
Shut the eff up you
Shut the eff up you bitch!
Uguhuhuhu! Uhuhuhuhu! Uhoohuhu, I sure do love these sewers!
These sewers are the best sewers I ever saw.
(unintelligible redneck noises)
I can't wait to die! Again! Hi friend! You lookin' good today! Oh, don't wanna play with me, I unnerstand.
God golly, these monsters sure are scary! Hope they don't rip off my penis...and shove my balls down my throat!
That would sure be painful awahgogaghah
Great, now my vision is shaking, that's a good sign,
[hissing]
I'm sure I'll collapse of fright any minute now. Haha!
Hahaha! Haven't seen the frickin' generator in ages! Whaaatever!
I am just - I'm gonna fall over, I'm gonna fall over, die of fright, that is gonna be the end of it.
That is just gonna be the end! And I don't care anymore! Your stupid face doesn't even bother me!
I-I - I - I do not get it! I do not get it!
I'm to the point in the game where my character is shaking, I found the very end of the note trail,
and nothing! I found nothing! Not even the glowsticks!
AH! Shut the f - gh fuck you, I don't even care. I don't care!
I don't care! I haven't even run once! This is the first time I'm running!
Left left left left left...and oh look, I'm back at the beginning! Hooray!
HOH, look at this! I found something! I got the glowsticks, even though I'm about to keel over and die!
[boom]
I found the glowsticks, isn't that just delightful for me! Whoohoohoo!
If you make me - if you get me to find the keys and then you have me keel over and die, inches from the door, I will hate you, game! For the rest of my life!
I will - OH don't you make me do this, game! Don't play this game with me!
Do not play this game with me! Don't play this game with me!
Don't play this game with me!
Just let me out! Don't make me fall over and die! Don't do that to me! Don't break my heart!
Ah, don't break my heart! I have the keys! Do not, please, don't break my heart, game!
[hisses]
Do not break my heart! Please! Please! Please, I'm begging of you!
I'm begging of you! Just let me leave!
Just let me leave! No, just let me leave!
Is there something there? Just let me leave! Just let me go!
Just let me go!
Just let me go, please, please please, I'll give you anything. I'll give you so much of anything if you just let me go.
If you let me go home!
[hissing]
Please! Please! Please! I'm begging you! With every fiber of my being!
Please don't let that be a monster there. I am begging you! With everything that I have! Just let me go home!
I'm gonna keel over and die any second now, I've been playing too long! I been playing too long!
I've been playing too long!
(pants)
Imma fall over! This is it, the darkness is closing in on me!
Please! Lemme go HOOOME!
LEMME GO HOME!
Lemme go home! Please! PLEASE please please please!
Oh, I am begging you so hard right now! I do not wanna die! I don't wanna come this far...for nothing.
Please...game...please. Please, game. Game, please.
Please, game. Game, please. Please, game, game, please.
Please, game, plame, please.
Gamgamgamgam pleasepleasepleasepleasepleasepleaseplease.
Please please please please please!
I know! I know! I know! I just need the door! Just gimme the door!
Just gimme the door!
Is that the door, that's not the door! Why couldn't it be the door?
No! NOOOO!
NOOOOO GAAAHHAA! AAAHHHH AHHH
FUCKING FUCKING, I FUCKING
FUCK EVERYTHING! EVERYTHING CAN GO DIE!
I HATE MY LIFE! I HATE THIS GAME!